what do you make of the debacle at open
AI both Carl and and yosha I'll direct
it to you yosha first um there's
relatively little I can say because I
don't actually know what the reason was
for um the decision of the board uh to
fire
Theo firing the CEO is one of the very
few moves be Beyond providing advice
than the board can make I thought if the
board makes such a decision in a company
in which many of the core employees have
been hired by the CEO have been working
very closely and happily with the CEO uh
they will need to have a very solid case
and there needs to be a lot of
deliberation among core engineers and uh
players in the company before such a
decision is being made apparently that
has not been the case have difficulty to
understand why people behaved in the way
in which they did the outcome is that
open AI is more unified than ever it's a
uh basically 95% agreement about uh
employees that they are going to leave
the company if it doesn't reinstate the
CEO is almost unheard of this is like an
Easter European Communist dictatorship
is fake elections but it was not fake it
was basically people getting uh together
overnight and uh getting signatures for
a decision that greately impacts their
professional careers many of them are on
Visa that depend on continuous
employment uh within a company so they
enter actual risks for a time and uh I
also suspect that a lot of the
discussions that happened were Bluffs
right when the board uh said yes they
want to reinstate them but then waffled
and came out uh with Emser who is a
pretty good person but it's not clear
why the twitch CEO would be the right
person to lead open AI suddenly so I
don't even know whether the decision was
made because there were personal
disagreements about communication Styles
or whether it was about the direction of
the company where uh members of the
board felt that uh AI is going to be
developed too quickly and uh should be
uh slowed down significantly and um the
strategy of uh Sam Alman to r chpt at
the loss and making up for this by
speeding up the development and getting
more capital in and thereby basic
creating an AI or bus strategy for the
company might not be the right strategy
also the board members don't hold equity
in the company so uh this is the
situation where the outcome of that
decision is somewhat forced from their
own material incentives and it dep is
more aligned with their political or
ideal uh ideas that they might have or
the goals that they have and again not
all of them are hardcore AI researchers
some of them are uh I don't really know
what the particular discussions have
been in there and of course I have more
intimate speculations and some
discussions with people at openi but I
um I cannot disclose the speculations of
course and so at the moment I can only
summarize in some sense what's publicly
known and what you can read on Twitter
it's super exciting it has kept us all
awake for a few days uh it's a
fascinating drama uh and I'm somewhat
frustrated by people say oh my God this
is destroyed trust in open AI if
decisions can be so erratic because open
AI should be like a bureaucracy that is
not moving in 100 years no this is part
of something that is super Dynamic and
is changing all the time I I think that
what the board should probably have seen
is that the best possible outcome they
could have achieved is that open uh AI
is going to split that uh the best
possible in the sense of the board
trying to fire some Alman to change the
course of the company they would have
created one of the largest competitors
to open
Ai and uh so basically an anti- anti-
anthropic on the other side of open ey
that is focusing more on accelerating AI
research it would have been clear that
many of the core team members would join
it and it would destroy a lot of the
equity that open AI currently possesses
and it would take away large portions of
open largest customers
Microsoft so these are some
observations now
Sam so Sam is back now it was clear that
it would happen right this move by saan
Nadella to say he works now for
Microsoft happened not after negotiating
uh new Organization for a month it
happened after uh in an afternoon
right after it was announced that the
board now has another candidates that
they secretly got uh talked into taking
on this role Microsoft basically set up
as a threat okay they're all going to
come to us and every open AI person who
wants cannot join Microsoft and a
dedicated autonomous unit with details
that are yet to be announced but they're
not going to be materially worse of or
research wise worse of so this is a back
stop that Microsoft had to implement to
uh prevent its stock from tumbling on
Monday morning so Microsoft moved very
fast on Sunday and decided we are going
to make sure that we are not going to
create a situation that is worse for us
than it was before and uh this creates
enormous pressure on open AI to
basically decide either we are going to
be alone without most of the core
employees and without our business model
uh but having succeeded in uh what the
board wants or uh we accept the fact
that the board has been defeated and
some has not been entirely C with the
board when he said last June that the
board can just fire him if it disagrees
with
him because that's obviously not the
case because the board at the moment
where there's so much buyin for the from
the employees and the core investors and
uh customers of open AI they cannot just
fire the CEO without very good
reason and Carl what do you make of it
the whole
Fiasco um I was just listening with
Fascination I I I think you have more
than enough material to keep your
viewers engaged can I just ask that
so is is open eye going to be ingested
by Microsoft or not then do you think
open AI is going to survive by
itself some people are joking that open
AI schools is to make Google obsolete to
replace search by intelligence and
Google is too slow to deliver a product
to deal with this impending competition
open the eye has rapidly growing in the
last few months has hired a lot of of
people who are focusing on product and
customer
relationships uh the cor research team
has been growing much more
conservatively and uh I think that uh
Microsoft was a natural partner for open
AI in this regard because Microsoft is
able to make large Investments and yet
uh is possibly not as agile as Google
the risk that if open a would partner
with Google as a main customer that
Google at some point would just walk
away with the qu technology and some of
the qu researchers might be larger than
with Microsoft but they can only
speculate
there the full podcast with yosa Bach
and Carl friston on open AI as well as
artificial intelligence in general and
Consciousness is either out right now or
out shortly subscribe to get notified
also hey welcome back Sam subscribe to
theories of everything to get notified
of upcoming podcasts as there are new
fulllength podcasts every week on the
topics of mathematics physics
Consciousness Free Will and
AI and